all right we've been covering
individually all of the insane grifting
and praying and predatory behavior that
has been happening because of the virus
let's look at some of the instances
we've already covered and some of the
ones that we haven't these are not good
people
these are not good people God gave us
this productt yeah I believe yes how
many did we go out acai was who gave
this to us about 10 12 years ago and we
have it at our home we have it in cases
we use it all the time I have this and I
mean I don't think I'd have made it
without silver it for my throat in all
that absolutely because I've had this
and this is amazing why whatever so so
would you recommend is a doctor people
to have silver in their house for it you
never want to be without silver now so
many reasons never never you know this
is a staple top yes stated I think this
is a staple for your family yes and we
can talk more about it maybe we have
more time yeah I got time all I can say
is that it has been proven by the
government that it has the ability to
kill every pathogen it has ever been
tested on including SARS and HIV eight
seven seven seven eight nine two five
three not on the so Tuesday global
transmission I'm not gonna belabor this
I'm just gonna tell you that versus your
daily life and your gums and your teeth
and for regular viruses and bacteria the
patented nano silver we have the
Pentagon has come out and documented and
Homeland Security had said this stuff
kills the whole SARS corona family at
point-blank range well of course it does
it kills every virus uh-huh but it's
thickening they found that and then this
is a this is 13 years ago and the
Pentagon uses the product we have and
the product we have and private label is
about to be in Walmart coming up they
just order a massive crap ton of that
not the one they have is this even
better one that we have so I'm just
saying we're always cutting edge thank
to God I just I just go with the
research go with the spirit and we
always have it then the Nano
so
or toothpaste in the super blue with the
tea tree and the iodine that's the super
blue is amazing then we have the
whitening toothpaste that has the nano
silver and a lot more as well those are
both excellent item for sort our comics
will discount despite all the hell
breaking loose
we have sortable food in stock but we
have to package it and it's six to eight
weeks behind shipping it out to you
other people will lie to you
the big old Pinocchio noses we're not
that's what's going on you want storable
food you want to get delivered this
thing of it is that we're bad peaks in
about 12 weeks in the US the models show
so you'll get your food in force we're
not calm and it's high quality it's very
low price they haven't raised prices yet
but I'm told it's next week 24 store.com
put your hand on that television yes
thank you Jesus thank you Lord Jesus
he received your hailing yes now say it
I take it I have it I have it's mine
it's mine I thank you and praise you for
it yes and I forget if I have aught
against any and I praise you that I'm
well and hold I praise you that I'm
according to the Word of God
I'm healed yes and I consider not my own
body yes I consider not symptoms in my
body I consider not symptoms but only
that which God has promised only that
what the word has said by His stripes I
was healed and by His stripes I am
healed now I'm not the sick trying to
get healed
I'm the healed and the devil's trying to
give me the flu
three or whatever else kind of thing
he's trying yeah heal and well yes in a
sweet name this is a lung disease so the
healthier your lungs are the better your
chance it
you won't get infected but you can
battle the virus better smokers are
extremely vulnerable vapors are not
doing well but if you have that's
actually not true there was an article
about a medical study that showed that
vaping the whatever propofol something
chloride in a vape is actually
preventing people from getting propylene
glycol is method proven they also have
other side effects I don't think we
can't have it or vaping therapeutic I
think it's extremely therapeutic for me
only nobody else what we want to shoot
god I feel the holy spirit glory to God
[Music]
the Lord is going to honor our prayers
and let me say from the beginning of
being a Bible student with a hundred and
seventy thousand hours of study Hebrew
words Greek words Jewish history Israel
history parallels of history prophetic
parallels that if this were just a
man-made virus and they've call it an
evolutionary virus or doesn't matter
what it is if it were just a normal
thing then if we pray and repent it
would immediately be stopped if it was a
normal thing now if it is a permitted
thing meaning the hand of the Lord came
off the country for the abominations and
you got to read the Bible guys to
understand this and what makes sense
then there's nothing we can do except
pray and ask God to help us repent and
we're talking about national repentance
as well and turn to God for help and
then watch him began to work